well a huge deal was made yesterday
about a speech from the failed former
president donald trump in washington dc
it was billed as his triumphant and
defiant
return to washington dc of course it
didn't quite go as planned number one it
happened under the cloud
figuratively of a criminal federal
investigation into the former president
we learned about that yesterday as
donald trump was giving his speech
almost quite literally the speech was
for the america first policy institute
this is one of these non-profit
political nonprofits
and it was created
essentially around trump trump was
inaugurated in 2017 he would talk about
america first then they created the
america first policy institute it's sort
of supposed to appear to be kind of a
think tank it's just a wacky wacky
organization and trump gave this much
promoted speech and it was whacked trump
went full deep state conspiracy theories
trump pretended to be transgender it was
a complete and utter implosion and we
are going to look at and this is one of
the most deranged speeches that donald
trump has ever given and it's deranged
for two reasons number one
the speech lacks all context for what
happened during trump's presidency and
for the fact that he's currently under
criminal investigation it's sort of like
a just a fantasy world speech number two
it is stunning the degree of
authoritarianism that a supposed small
government movement now casually demands
and we will get to that part of the
speech as well
part of it is trump saying we just got
to make it easy to fire people and here
he pulls out the deep state conspiracy
theory in the swamp and root out the
deep state we need to make it much
easier to fire rogue bureaucrats who are
deliberately undermining democracy
or at a minimum just want to keep their
jobs they want to hold on to their jobs
congress should pass historic reforms
empowering the president to ensure that
any bureaucrat who is corrupt
incompetent or unnecessary for the job
can be told did you ever hear this
you're fired get out you're fired
have to do it
deep state
deep state
deep state is a conspiracy theory of a
sort of clandestine network of actors
involved in the federal government
involved in industry
involved in high-level finance and they
operate as a kind of hidden government
specifically deep state is sort of a
trump-aligned conspiracy theory but the
idea of a shadow government that is
really pulling the strings that's a very
very old conspiracy theory it's often
highly anti-semitic involving that it's
actually the jews pulling the strings
there are many versions of it
and
trump has bought into it full this is a
this is straight up conspiracy theory
whack job stuff
often there will be some kernel of truth
to hang on to and the kernel of truth is
people with money tend to have power in
the united states that is true and it
has been blown up
into the supposed anti-trump deep cover
conspiracy theory and trump just openly
talking about it now now trump also
regularly overtly transphobic now during
his speeches he did it here as well and
here in this clip donald trump pretends
to lift weights first impersonating i
guess what he believes to be
a quote real female weightlifter
and then impersonating a trans
weightlifter this is a staple now of
trump's speeches kevin's saying he can
lift it
i don't know about that kevin but that's
a lot 218 pounds and she got over that
weight and she was gonna break it they
put a half an ounce here half little
tiny ring on top of these big
barbells dumbbells
and they go and she go in like this and
she got a break
stood for 11 years
and her mother and father are screaming
you got it
you got it darling i'm so proud of my
girl
she couldn't do it
and then
this guy comes along
he's named alice
[Applause]
and he looks at the
way world record world record
we could have put another couple of
hundred pounds on i think he would have
lifted him
so regularly misgendering people
ridiculing trans athletes by the way
inventing scenarios that are completely
imaginary and this is now
overtly acceptable
in these contexts this is this america
first policy institute it's supposed to
be
more of a buttoned up serious policy
think tank arm of the delusional
trumpist maga america first nonsense and
it's not turning out that way because
trump is on stage pretending to be trans
now continuing the horrible
authoritarianism trump announces his
plan for the homeless and it's basically
to create tent cities where you put
homeless people in tents all kinds from
all places
lying along the roads that's without the
tents
and then you look at the tents and the
homeless
and you say what's happening to this
great bastion
perhaps some people will not like
hearing this but the only way you're
going to remove the hundreds of
thousands of people and maybe throughout
our nation millions of people we're
talking now two things here one they are
now also selling gold coins
alongside trump's speech on newsmax and
secondly understand the absurdity trump
bemoans the horrible nature of homeless
people living in tents in cities and his
solution is make homeless people live in
tents outside of cities that's the
solution talking about
and help make our cities clean safe and
beautiful again
is open up large parcels of inexpensive
land and the outer reaches of the cities
bring medical professionals
including doctors psychiatrists
psychologists
right all the medical professionals
trump ignored for for years during covet
rehab specialists
build permanent bathrooms and other
facilities make them good make them hard
you need your sink
you need your shower
and you need your third third element of
the bathroom but build them fast
and create
thousands and thousands of high quality
tents which can be done in one day one
day
and you have to move people out now some
people say oh that's so horrible no
what's horrible
is what's happening now right so trump
really displeased with all of the
homeless people living in tents in
cities we've got to do something for
them we really do so we're going to move
them to tents
outside of the cities and the tents will
be a little bit better and we will have
doctors there
uh really really wild authoritarian
stuff trump then of course going through
his pity me part of the speech where he
said he's been treated even worse than
richard nixon i guess that's the point
he's trying to make
who else could have taken this
you know think of it nixon went through
not even one impeachment
and i think he always regretted that he
didn't fight
but uh people uh
it's been a very interesting period of
time yeah just treated so terribly trump
you know subjected to multiple
impeachments that even nixon didn't go
through that
at another point in the speech donald
trump claimed that we charge the country
25 000
for each person that comes in illegally
i assume he means we build the source
country so like if a mexican person
comes in illegally we bill mexico for 25
grand of all of the bad ones and the
police know almost immediately who the
bad ones are and that we could do and
that we can do fast and easy at the same
time we should implement a bond system
and a financial penalty so that anyone
who comes to our country on a temporary
visa and fails to depart
suffers significant financial
consequences and we take the money away
from the country we charge the country
25 000 each for each person that comes
in illegally notice that there's almost
no policy during these bizarre speeches
but when you get something that sounds
like policy it's number one completely
absurd and obviously unworkable
diplomatically and also the crowd
collapse because they don't seem to know
any better at all
at another moment donald trump talked
about democratic congressman adam schiff
and trump's increasingly focused on
schiff's personal appearance and the
shape of schiff's head referring to it
regularly now to be watermelon shaped
and it's dessert think of this these are
hacks and thugs you're the same people
that we've been dealing with for four
years same people
and it's the
very people who
perpetrated the lies that i was an agent
of russia like adam shifty chef and
others
who are standing before the same
microphone same thing they get out and
they say oh our country
is suffering so badly because and he
knows the whole thing is a hoax
i said this the other day he knew russia
russia was a hoax him hillary clinton
the dnc the democrats
and he stood pompously before
microphones
his head as you know i feel is shaped
like a
watermelon trump's head is really small
by the way
he's quite an unattractive man
now see they'll get me in trouble for
that kellyanne because by saying he's
unattractive they'll say that's a
horrible thing to say
but he said slightly worse about
me
right and it's right he did even worse
okay so
then we go into the full authoritarian
part of the speech where trump again has
this almost like a wet dream of sending
military into cities to quote restore
order despite the governor's wishes all
of a sudden not super concerned with
states rights where there is a true and
total breakdown of law and order where
citizens most basic rights have been
violated then the federal government can
and should send the national guard to
restore order and secure the peace
without having to wait for the approval
of some governor
that thinks it's politically incorrect
the party of states rights says we
should be allowed to send in the
military whenever we want amen
[Applause]
when governors refuse to protect their
people we need to bring in what's
necessary anyway we have to go beyond
the governor
another 60 people
were shot
think of this it's not even possible
were shot in chicago over the weekend
yes in afghanistan with many many with
firearms that whose providence is
originally
purchases in the neighboring state of
indiana with very lacks gun laws
afghanistan for 18 months not one of our
soldiers
was killed
and they had that number of people shot
in chicago over the weekend think of it
and he died by the way many died
when that many are shot
a lot are going to die and this is
constant in chicago and this cannot go
on anymore
every other approach has been considered
and tried yeah you know the thing that
hasn't been tried is actually dealing
with the guns but trump wants to send in
the troops very very small government
states rights conservative okay last
couple things after to go back to the
trans part tr anti-trans is such a big
part now of trump's speeches when trump
finishes up a rant attacking trans youth
and trans athletes he says his idea for
winning with a basketball team would be
to convince lebron james to be a woman
so unfair
[Applause]
it's so unfair
and i'll tell you what if i were ever
i'd be the greatest women's basketball
coach in history
because i don't like lebron james i like
michael jordan much better
but i'd go up to lebron james it doesn't
matter say lebron did you ever have any
desire to be a woman
because what i'd love you to do is star
on my team that i'm building up i will
have the greatest team in history
they'll never lose
nobody will come within 70 points of
this team
now we have to change that and we have
to make it okay to talk about it you
know the young lady i was talking about
is afraid to talk about it she's shunned
and she's canceled when she talks about
it yep so there's trump's big idea for
basketball and then lastly just maybe
the dumbest part of the speech
altogether trump rants about windshield
wipers true i said i can't talk about it
i complained i said i did too good a job
i did too good a job that's like
obsolescence you know a windshield wiper
for those of you i used to drive cars
haven't been driving too many lately but
for those for those of you that complain
you buy a windshield wiper right
and it lasts for one year then it
doesn't work anymore you can't see you
got to get another one they could make
the wiper good for 100 years
but they want planned obsolescence the
same thing is happening yeah i guess
trump doesn't realize you just grab a
paper towel you pinch your wiper and
wipe it and then it's like back to new
but you know we we i guess i can't
expect trump to know that so
under a cloud of a criminal federal
investigation against trump he shows up
to deliver what was supposed to be this
historic triumphant defiant principled
speech and he rants about trans athletes
authoritarian wet dreams of sending the
national guard into democratic uh states
and windshield wipers folks
this guy could be the next president
we'll have these clips on our instagram
which you can find at david pakman show
i'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today is helix sleep i sleep on
a helix mattress at home i absolutely
love it and that's why i reached out to
them about sponsoring the david pakman
show
buying a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness i generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both gq and wired magazine it
is well deserved i can tell you
firsthand every helix mattress comes
with a 10 year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights and they will even come pick
it up at your house if you don't love it
but i know you will for a limited time
helix is offering up to three hundred
and fifty dollars off all mattress
orders plus two free pillows at helix
sleep.com
pacman it's the biggest discount they've
ever offered the link is down below